Vegeta the super elite Prince born of
the Saiyan race for being raised under
the umbrella of Freitas evil tyrannical
rule to fighting in defense of his own
universe amongst the gods having now
become one of the strongest beings in
existence Vegeta still yearns to push
his body further to break through his
own limits and to reach his ultimate
goal
surpassing Kakarot but he hasn't always
been this strong and how strong is he
it's been a long and troubled road for
the Saiyan Prince and we are here to
discuss that today so let's take a step
onto the rollercoaster that is Vegeta's
character arc and using as many official
references as we can try and find out
what is Vegeta's power level he's the
Prince of all Saiyans I'm totally not
mark and this is the power level series
episode 6 Vegeta Vegeta is a member of
the warrior race known as Saiyans he is
roughly 53 years old when you take into
account the fact he has never been dead
for an extended period of time and he
has spent roughly five point five years
in the hyperbolic time chamber bringing
his age from 48 up to 53 his techniques
and transformations include the BIGBANG
attack the Gallic gun final flash the
Super Saiyan transformation and the
Super Saiyan blue transformation Vegeta
has four officially stated power levels
in this series those being 18,000 twenty
four thousand thirty thousand and two
hundred and fifty thousand Vegeta the
characters introduced the story via
Raddatz after his defeat at the hands of
both piccolo and Goku through the
scouter of go who's fallen brother both
Vegeta and nappa here of the Earth's
Dragon Balls and so make a beeline for
the planet in the hopes that their wish
for immortality will be granted now
before I begin talking numbers I want
everyone to try to remember that small
piece of information regarding Vegeta's
character motivation it's vital and very
telling seeing as it's a motivation from
before Vegeta met Goku
I'll reference it later something else
that's worth noting is that Vegeta
refers to rad as a pitiful guy for not
being able to handle a couple of
fighters with battle powers in the
region of 1000 however once he gets a
reading of the likes of piccolo Gohan
and krillen in person one year later he
is amazed that they're improving
specifically with Goku not only has Goku
gotten stronger than he was from one
year ago but he is quite possibly one of
the strongest Saiyans Vegeta has ever
seen if not
regardless on strong cocoa has become
this doesn't phase Vegeta while Goku at
this time has an impressive power level
of 8000 Vegeta's max is 18,000 however
the battle goes south for Vegeta once
Goku utilizes the kaio-ken technique
with increasing intensity
this forces vegeta to use the Oh Zahraa
form to regain control of the fight on
fact the O's our form gives the user at
times 10 multiplier meaning that
Vegeta's full power in that form was
180,000 no wonder Goku was helpless
naturally and as you all know Vegeta is
defeated and as Crillon tangles the sort
of Damocles above Vegeta's head goku
insists that he be spared to afford him
the opportunity to fight with the same
prince once again embarrass and beaten
the Gaea takes his leave to recover one
of freezes conquered worlds it's in that
moment Vegeta vows to surpass Goku and
defeat him but first
Vegeta has a larger fish to fry on
Planet Namek the home of the Dragon
Balls at this point in the series
Vegeta's main motivation is revenge
revenge on the galactic dictator Frieza
for destroying his home planet that he
was destined to rule to achieve this his
primary plan of action is to collect the
seven Dragon Balls of Namek and wish for
immortality so that he may defeat Frieza
during Vegeta's light-hearted carefree
adventures collecting the wish orbs
endemic he undergoes three zenkai boosts
for those of you who don't know as NK
boost is a powerup specific to the
Saiyan race every warrior has a base
power level however if a stay in
sustains serious injury during battle
and recovers from said injury their
power level increases substantially and
Vegeta has enjoyed three of these since
he last battled with Goku on earth the
first same guy came once he recovered in
the rejuvenation tank actress battle
with Goku once healed of the Jesus power
increased from 18,000 to 24,000 or a 33%
increase bestowing upon him enough power
to send both Kui and de Doria to the
next dimension
the second Zheng Kai for Vegeta came
after he attempted to take down Zarb on
Vegeta now being able to sense power
levels thanks to his time spent on earth
is confident in his ability to take down
when it freezes most elite soldiers
however Vegeta having no prior knowledge
of czar bonds transformation abilities
was easily taken out and left for dead
at the bottom of a namekian lake luckily
for Vegeta though he was already in
possession of a dragon ball and then
hidden it somewhere on the planet so
therefore if Frieza was to have any hope
of finding that try
Vegeta needed to live this was friezes
single biggest mistake during the Namek
saga I believe once healed Vegeta
strength increased by 25% to 30,000 but
that's not all once escaped from the
rejuvenation tank he dashed to the other
side of the ship to cause tremendous
damage this was a decoy Vegeta while
masking his power dashes back to the
holding bay of freezes ship to
successfully steal all the Dragon Balls
in his possession
this is Vegeta at his absolute best I
think with this new power Vegeta is able
to take out a fully transformed zarba
things are looking up for Vegeta
meanwhile back with Frieza oh they're
dead why are they dead the final and
probably most enormous increase Vegeta
receives on Planet Namek comes when to
eat the sense of being given to him by
Goku after his fight with Roku at that
point his power level shoots up to
250,000 yielding a multiplier of 8.3
it should be noted that all the power
levels I've supplied for Vegeta thus far
were provided by official sources and
guidebooks from here on in it's that
time again time for some good
old-fashioned mental gymnastics that
lasts NK boost I mentioned doesn't go
unnoticed by Vegeta either clearly at a
normal increase he claims that it could
be that he is drawing nearer to the
Super Saiyan threshold perhaps this
small extract sheds light on why Vegeta
Gohan and Goku go through such enormous
power increases in such a short amount
of time during this period however this
is just speculation we're here to talk
numbers first form Frieza has a power
level officially stated as being 530,000
it's important to note that at this
point Vegeta isn't aware that Frieza can
transform which is why he is confident
that he can take down Frieza with the
help of Gohan and krillen this tells us
that at the time of this battle Vegeta
has a power level in the region of
500,000 or maybe less
I'm guessing this figure based on how he
performed against Frieza while also
noting he believes he needs the help of
Gohan and krillen once Frieza transforms
into his second state with a power level
of over 1 million Vegeta is frozen
unable to do anything this is another
key instance that sheds light on
Vegeta's character one which I will
again refer to later he remains frozen
that is until he gets an idea an idea to
take advantage of his own say in biology
he asks of Crillon to bring him to the
brink of death asking this knowing full
well that Dende is on the ground
having just healed both Crillon and
Gohan earlier in the fight exactly what
Regina needs or so he thinks
now how strong did Vegeta get thanks to
that Zheng Kai let's have a look at some
quotes piccolo at this time has a power
level roughly of 1.2 million he does not
stand a chance against third form
freezer and Vegeta has assessed Frieza
third form Frieza at this time is using
significantly less than 3-million Bala
power also seeing as when Goku arrives
he is able to deflect freezes blasts
without the use of the Kaioken oh yeah
it's important to remember that Goku
when he arrives in the battlefield has
an officially stated power level of 3
million right so taking into account
third form Frieza was dealing with both
piccolo and Gohan with relative ease
it's fair to assume he is in the region
of 1.5 to 1.8 million and Vegeta knows
this once Frieza transforms into his
final state he is most likely using
somewhere in the region of 2 to 2.2
million or 1.6 percent of his max power
what's worth noting however is that over
the last wild Vegeta has been
experiencing massive boosts that slowly
roll out over time it's as if he
discovers how strong he has become as he
fights for example after a [ __ ] he is
250,000 but by the time he faces freezer
he's become around 500,000 increases of
this magnitude are new to Vegeta at this
point in his life therefore when he
fights Frieza in his final form
initially he might be able to follow
what's going on but as soon as freeze it
begins to turn it up slightly he isn't
able to keep up anymore resulting in him
realizing his limits and ultimately his
death therefore with that taken into
account I would estimate his power level
to be at this point somewhere in the
neighborhood of 1.8 to 2 million
significantly less than Goku but more
than freezes third form this figure
works as it allows room for Vegeta to be
confident he could defeat Frieza but
once he sends his Goku strength is more
confident in his abilities now as many
of you guys might remember Vegeta in the
anime once he is revived using the
domeki and Dragon Balls head straight to
Goku who has become a Super Saiyan then
disappears before Freitas eyes as he has
wished to earth this would lead many to
believe that Vegeta knows the strength
of Goku at that time giving him time to
look Coco up and down how you doing
and since his power level but I was
surprised to find out that that does not
happen in the manga at all in the manga
Vegeta wakes up is confused and teleport
earth still confused once on earth
Vegeta when he overhears go
calling his father a Super Saiyan is in
shock this is relevant because we now
know that Vegeta has no reference for
how strong a Super Saiyan is in relation
to himself well not until trunks that is
but first let's consider that within the
last year Vegeta has been training
intensely though not as intensely as he
would in the following three years it
should be noted that everyone including
Vegeta is blown away by this power that
trunks is demonstrating giving Vegeta
his first glimpse into a Super Saiyans
true power
however trunks is not necessarily as
strong as Goku autonomic he could be
stronger looking at this quote once Goku
returns to earth he at least thought it
conceivable that Vegeta may have taken
care of Frieza obviously being one year
forward since freezes flies with Goku
Goku knows more about the Super Saiyan
transformation and what it does to one's
power therefore he could sense Vegeta
ski and estimate that given the amount
of strength he has at that time could
have defeated Frieza had he transformed
meaning he would need to be 2.5 million
or more if he was to hit the 120 million
max power Frieza is confirmed to be at
by the guide books on Nanak what is the
news of the androids breaks for
approximately three years Vegeta
undergoes intense training in the
gravity chamber designed by boas father
in solitude when vegeta meets with
android 18 he isn't able to keep up with
her for very long having both of his
arms broken to the process thanks to
piccolo we now know that the androids
have a power level in the region of 360
million and trunks have a power level in
the region of 170 million or more
depending on what training he did if he
did any training and just skip to the
time period Vegeta is said to be even
greater than trunks by commies so he
must currently fall in between trunks
and 18 strength somewhere given how long
he was able to take Android 18s attacks
and given that Android 17 said that he
was impressed I'd be inclined to believe
that he was much closer to her power
than he was trunks giving him an
estimated power level in the region of
300 million at most as a Super Saiyan
and 6 million at most in his base form
this figure makes sense as well given
the way that he carries himself in this
portion of the series before piccolo
merges he knows he is vastly stronger
than all the other Z fighters and
although the heart virus stipulation
with Goku makes him difficult to measure
at this stage this quote might be
something to go by where piccolo calls
Vegeta a fighting genius that may have
even surpassed Goku now this next part
is very important when it comes to
looking at why people are as strong as
they are in the future allow me to
explain this
having recently come to terms with his
defeat at the hands of Android 18 and
just after seeing that piccolo is
stronger than him
Vegeta ventures off into the wastelands
of earth looking to the horizon this
moment flies by really quickly and only
haven't gone back over this section of
the manga for this series numerous times
have I noticed it looking at this quote
from Goku agreed Vegeta is a genius all
right he's beginning to see beyond Super
Saiyan power ascension past the Super
Saiyan form isn't something that someone
can do through training alone state of
mind is a large practice play in it as
well go who stated that Vegeta is
beginning to see beyond Super Saiyan
power lends well to this statement by
trunks after his time in the chamber
with his father now as I'm sure you are
all aware of both Vegeta and trunks
enter the time chamber and according to
trunks Vegeta surpassed Super Saiyan
grade two months after entering the
chamber the remaining ten were I suppose
further exploration into his abilities
and perfecting the form in short he
learned fast and trained a boatload
after I should mention the suppressed
Super Saiyan state he is referring to is
called Super Saiyan grade two one of
four grades calm before Super Saiyan 2
taking into consideration that he is now
much stronger than Android 16 and cell
who absorbed Android 17 most likely put
him in the region of 1.25 billion
capable of exceeding this when going
all-out not nearly as strong as Goku or
go on after their time in the chamber
but still much stronger themselves
second form who add most clocks in
around 1 billion as you might have seen
from my previous video where I discussed
Gohan's journey I also discussed cells
through power from that we learned that
perfect cell achieved a power level in
the region of 2.5 to 3 billion barracks
eating Super Saiyan grade 2 after
charging his final flash he was able to
inflict serious damage to cell however
thanks to cell's regeneration ability
this was for nothing
and even though Vegeta did reenter the
time chamber for one additional time
more than Goku and Gohan he has still
yet to surpassed a mile so Goku and
Gohan have said of Super Saiyan grade 4
from the quote earlier regarding Vegeta
looking past the power of a Super Saiyan
it seems fair to claim that one must do
the same when achieving the various
grades of Super Saiyan even cell points
out Vegeta's inferiority to Goku being
weaker than both Goku and Gohan during
this time would put him somewhere in the
region of 1.8 billion in my estimation
judging by how he looked on it all at
both Goku and Gohan while they were in
combat with cell and that's pretty much
Vegeta for the cell saga after they
there is a seven-year time skip towards
the beginning of the Buu saga I guess
from this quote it's fair to assume that
Vegeta is as powerful or more powerful
than Gohan was after he transformed
against L so I guess that means he's in
the region of around 5 billion it should
be noted here that Bob Lee drug Vegeta's
hidden power make him stronger than he
was prior so given that piccolo is
claiming that Vegeta's unleash power
could be more powerful than Gohan when
he faced cell that would put him in the
region of 5.5 billion to 6 billion
during this time he believes it's
conceivable not a foregone conclusion
I'm not going to sit here and say that
he was 10 times stronger because he
simply wasn't according to the original
writings who already that's the easy
part over the part that made some
semblance of sense the next part is
where things go so off-the-wall
unbelievable that it makes me want to
just claw my eyes out using rusty Forks
but I digress I'm going to put down the
forks this is a power level series and
we shall boldly go where few men have
been insane enough to venture so let's
go we first see Vegeta in Dragon Ball
super when he is on vacation with his
family this all takes place roughly
three to four years after the events of
Dragon Ball Z however whether or not
Vegeta is significantly stronger than he
was in Dragon Ball Z is unknown to us
just for the sake of consistency let's
say he increased the 7 billion
assumptions already I love it through
the series for Vegeta in Dragon Ball
super specifically I decided that the
best way to tackle this was to make
bullet points representing each
individual time batida gained a
significant increase in power and so I
present Aaron's students is where
Vegeta's power and grease
Super Saiyan rage versus beerus printing
under weeks before Goku trading under
weaves with Goku three years in the
hyperbolic time chamber Vegeta goes into
the hyperbolic time chamber for six
months during the time span between the
Future Trunks arc and the universe
survival our Vegeta is seen training ie
during the episodes where hit is to
assassinate Goku however before we move
forward with this line of thinking we
must first understand Super Saiyan God
and what exactly it is or at least try
to based on the limited amount of
information available to us right now
well in preparation for this episode I
extracted every instance beerus
mentioned - strength or Goku strength
and try to drive an estimate from that
conversation that took place over 4
episodes however while boring in time
consuming it revealed very little it's
almost like it's designed to be
ambiguous but I did gather something
I'll show you the Cliff Notes version so
that we can at least try to be on the
same page
episode 10 nowhere in the universe is
there anyone stronger than me the god of
destruction
you two are rather unrecognizable from
how you were back on north Kyser world
episode 12 i is this super saiyan gods
limit beerus you're incredible I hate to
say it but I I don't think I can keep up
with you anymore you fought well during
this exchange beerus is breathing
heavily does this mean that beerus is
going all-out or was he lying
episode 13 what a surprise were you
still hiding power I'm a god you know
for me to go all-out against is saying
I'd rather die than humiliate myself
like that or so I thought until just now
I realized that I really don't want to
lose this stupid fight I'll beat you
soundly improved I am overwhelmingly
stronger than you this is my 100% and
then later in that very same episode
despite being just as saying you made me
use this much of my power
you're admirable again later in that
same episode what with Goku retaining
all the strength from the Super Saiyan
God form when that happened I didn't
feel like I got any weaker at all it
seems that the Super Saiyan God's power
did not disappear even though time ran
out rather it fully merged with and
became part of you the gods red shine is
still burning like a raging fire inside
of you and finally episode 14 after Goku
drives beerus from the ocean to the
stratosphere with one punch the Super
Saiyan God made from the power of five
Saiyans cobbled together practically a
patchwork you perfected it by making it
your own and with it drove me to use
this much of my power just between us
for a moment there I actually regretted
being so obsessed with that pathetic
dream and so from that we know that
beerus is lying that's pretty much the
size of it and that he is much much
stronger than he is displaying here
which is of no help to me however it did
remind me on some level of the worm and
the man's story for those of you that
don't know a man is walking down the
street going about his business when he
see the worm on the side of the pavement
wriggling he thinks to himself what a
primitive creature he doesn't even know
I'm here
the worm is limited to his meager
understanding of what his senses
physical being and intelligence allowed
however the man wonders what if we
humans were just a worm to some other
greater entity outside of our
comprehension unable to understand or
fathom what could very well be thinking
the very same thing about us we would
have no idea that it's there the same
way the worm has no idea that we're here
now allow me to twist this store
right to fit Dragon Balls narrative what
if you were walking down the street when
suddenly you notice a worm and instead
of wriggling it throws a tiny pebble at
you you say wow I've never seen any worm
managed to do that that's incredible so
you pay closer attention
beerus a character who craved the
challenge seeing as he has been living
in a universe of zero competition for
what must be longer than you can
comprehend
therefore he challenges the worm more
and more and gradually it becomes more
capable until finally it manages the
strength to lightly push your hand away
from it if you were beerus you would
immediately take notice and say sure is
something I've never seen anything like
that before
this worm or in this case Saiyan is
special that is how beerus views goku
and why he is concerned with pushing him
in the direction of getting stronger
it's why he pretends there are other
beings in the same universe as him that
are even stronger example Menaka
a being that has wandered his domain for
an enormous amount of time relative to
you or i witnessed a worm crawled from
the earth and show him something he
never thought to be even possible
beerus at no point during this
confrontation tried he exerted himself
but in a very limited capacity it's
important to understand the scale of
what we are talking about here - I've
heard the terms galaxy level power
universe level power the latter of which
obviously being the stronger of the two
however even though people know that
both beerus and champa are capable of
destroying a universe they do not like
the idea of power levels getting
absurdly large so hopefully with this
example I can help put things into
perspective so how big is our galaxy the
Milky Way that contains our solar system
let's look at our solar system Sun for
scale firstly our Sun is so large it can
fit 1 million 300,000 earths inside of
it so if we were to shrink our Sun to
the size of a white blood cell the Milky
Way in scale would be around the size of
the United States of America and that's
just a galaxy not a universe according
to scientists in the observable universe
there are over 100 billion galaxies feel
small yet at that scale if you were
traveling at the equivalent of the speed
of light you would travel a whole mile
in just about 35 years so you can see
the power output of beerus isn't just
insane it's on a whole other level
outside of our comprehension
I think people forget just how
impossibly huge the universe is and the
fact that we can travel to earth in
about 25 minutes is rather impressive
also
how did mortals use their power to
transcend this level and gain the
interest of the gods
while in truth it's not the same power
not even close
multiple times in the series it has been
made abundantly clear that when divine
key is channeled it is not the same as
normal key in short mortal key is
distinctly different from divine key or
God key people seem to liken it to a
pressure they feel when being faced
against it actually if a Scouter was to
be held up in front of beerus it
wouldn't register or calculate anything
it's like using your eyes to smell
something well you want but it's not
going to work however unlike your eye is
not being able to smell something
characters can through constant training
and exposure alert to sense it but again
it's important to note that they are
completely different things and this
will be important later this God key
enables users to transcend the mortal
limits and truly become something new
and groundbreaking the only thing we
know about beerus is power so far in
terms of scaling is that Goku utilizing
the Kaioken times 10 in his super saiyan
blue form is still not a challenge to
beerus this is actually confirmed by him
in that arc specifically regarding the
Future Trunks arc the Dragon Ball super
producer at sushi key though was asked
who's the strongest out of all of these
referring to the cast of fighters in
Dragon Ball Kido said the god of
destruction beerus is overwhelmingly
strong but if we leave him out then i
think the strongest fighter is goku
black i'd say he used son goku power as
a base and evolved it in his own unique
way the producer of the show doesn't
even sound sure but I digress let's get
back to Vegeta
Vegeta's initial fight with beerus in
the my Bulma scene showcased a
significantly more successful effort
than what Goku demonstrated on King
Kai's planet and by a wide margin
similar to my last episode with Gohan
Super Saiyan rage is not a measurable
quantity it's purely a plot device that
allows the wielder to at that time rise
to the occasion for a brief period
and while short beerus does acknowledge
Vegeta's efforts as being noticeably
stronger than goku z' best during Goku's
battle with lord beerus vegeta spends
his time watching from the ship looking
straight up into the sky this is very
reminiscent of this scene Vegeta is
staring off into the horizon after 18
and piccolo having been faced by an
individual he cannot sense or fathom
this scene believe it or not I think is
Vegeta in the middle of training Wiest
notices this and tries to interact with
the prince but his efforts are to no
avail as Vegeta remains eyes locked to
the sky in a trance
in this moment he is trying to learn to
send Scott key and towards the end of
the fight he does just that
Goku said it first Vegeta is a genius
now for us to move further through the
story I need beerus is full power level
if hypothetically god energy was
converted to regular energy that is and
this is where i'm not going to lie for
the sake of making a more interesting or
controversial video it's important to me
that i produce quality content while
trying to be as informative as i can and
as i am making this video currently
there is no measurable way of discerning
how strong beerus is no matter who tells
you otherwise however with that said I'm
going to try to get as accurate a figure
as I can and in doing that I will leave
an asterisk next to it that will signify
that if more information comes out
regarding lord beerus it can be subject
to change I'm doing this specifically
with lord beerus as he has the least
information from which to derive an
average he also directly affects other
characters in the series such as Goku
and Vegeta in an interview Toriyama was
quoted in saying in fact from the
beginning - even now I have no plans for
Goku and Vegeta to surpass beerus and
whis this quote is indicative of beerus
and weeks serving only as constantly
rising ceilings for which Vegeta and
Goku must stay beneath and the stronger
they get as characters so too does
beerus and wheezes sealing in the eyes
of Toriyama and the Toei animation staff
that is until the time comes when Goku
finally surpasses bierce which still has
not happened in either the anime or the
manga so with that said let's see what
we can do with what little we have Goku
is quoted in saying that even if Vegeta
and himself fused he thinks that that
might not even be enough it's important
to know here that he is going off of the
fight he just had with beerus where he
was barely using a fraction of a
strength so how strong is vegeta in the
super-exciting guides published by
Shueisha it states that fusion of vegeto
is Goku X Vegeta which is the
mathematical donation meaning to
multiply so let's assume that both of
these characters have the same base
power level at this time let's also
estimate them to be in the region of 70
million in their base states which means
if we were to multiply 70 million by 70
million Vegeta's based power level would
be 4.9 quadrillion at his base power
level if we are to go off the
super-exciting guides that is multiply
that by 50 and we get super video
standing with a par level output of 245
quadrillion give or take and so let's
further assume that beerus was using 0.1
percent of his strength against Goku he
have been using even less or more it's
impossible to tell but let's just use
this figure for simplicity sake
that would put beerus in the region of
245 quintillion well that seems like a
fittingly ridiculous figure so beerus is
sitting high and mighty over all of
creation living up to his name the god
of destruction and so let's put the
super saiyan blue stage when it was
first reached at around 2 to 4 percent
of beerus is total strength god i hate
numbers this lends well to the viewpoint
that super saiyan blue kaio-ken is not
something that can directly challenge
beerus but a staff is something not to
sneeze at nowadays I would guess Vegeta
while wielding the Super Saiyan blue
form would generate roughly 8% of beerus
'as total power again I'm using beerus
as the benchmark here seeing as he is
the ceiling that neither Goku or Vegeta
are allowed to surpass keeping that in
mind
Super Saiyan blue I would have in the
region of nineteen point six quintillion
this is the power I would estimate him
having after the Future Trunks Ark he is
seen training here and there during the
episodes between the Future Trunks ark
and the universe survival are how much
though is unclear during the build-up to
the universe survival ark he is seen for
the first time not to be training I also
have no idea how long this was to be the
case for Vegeta so I said firmly on my
figure of nineteen point six quintillion
it troubles many many fans that Vegeta
has been treated as a weaker lesser
character to Goku but in truth it's
absolutely 100% in his character to be
that way it's been foreshadowed numerous
times in the series throughout this
video I refer to many instances of the
story as being significant and important
the first was the reason why Vegeta came
to earth in the first place it was to
make his wish for immortality on the
Dragon Balls this was his way of
defeating Frieza it was the only way he
thought it was possible to defeat him
but once that fell through and he was
faced with the true power of Frieza he
froze and was terrified the second
instance of this came during the cell
saga Vegeta didn't even consider that a
level could exist beyond a super saiyan
and this is indicative of his ego he
does not train to better himself he
trains to be better than others which
means that he will always be second best
to Goku eventually there is an instant
similar to this one actually in the
universe sixth tournament dark before
Vegeta and Goku enter the time chamber
Vegeta doesn't believe that they can get
stronger than what they currently are
mapping out calculations based on
limited to no in
is very difficult and admittedly not too
fun I apologize that this wasn't the
explanation that you were looking for
but in saying that I am sure there are
dozens of other explanations you could
take a look at Vegeta is easily a
contender for the best character Dragon
Ball has ever produced having gone
through dramatic changes from his time
on the same saga to modern day it's no
wonder he remains a fresh and
interesting character in Super this has
been by far the most challenging episode
of the series with that said I
absolutely want to hear your guys take
on things how strong do you think Vegeta
is during the Saiyan am excel and majin
buu work and how do you calculate or
rationalize super saiyan blue next week
is the series finale with Goku and I
hope I can see all of you guys there
this has been the power level series
I've been totally not mark and as always
thank you so much for watching